faced with such an aggressive agenda of
cuts the jobs conditions pay in pensions
the rnt has no choice but to defend our
members
industrially and to stop this race to
the bottom
the strikes on network rail the train
operators and london underground will go
ahead
and we again call on our members
to stand firm
support the action
mount the pickets and demonstrate their
willingness
to fight for workplace justice
the rmt supports the campaign for a
square deal for all working people
in the face of the cost of living crisis
and our current campaign
is a part of that more general campaign
that means that public services have to
be properly funded and all workers paid
properly with good conditions
we remain available for discussions
during the action and after the action
and between the strike dates if the
companies want to engage with us
but we are firmly of the belief that the
only way for us to settle this dispute
is for grant shapes and the government
to allow these companies to negotiate
and let the parties reach a reasonable
agreement
that will end the disruption of the
service
will secure jobs and allow a decent
transport system to be developed in this
country
thanks very much for
your listening so special
well we're not special the whole country
is suffering
and we have got a membership and a trade
union that is prepared to fight for what
we've got
what the rest of the country suffers
from is the lack of power
the lack of the ability to organize and
the lack
of the
wherewithal to take on these employers
that are continually driving down wages
and making the working class in this
country poorer year on year on year
while the rich get richer
and dividends are accelerated and the
stock market is reasonably healthy we've
got full employment
we've got full employment and falling
wages and that is a situation that has
never happened before and it cannot be
tolerated by working people or by the
trade union movement